Speaker 1: The Russian invasion of Ukraine
continues. And I want to get everybody up to speed
there before we move on to other things. And as
always, when we say we have a report of something,
that's what we mean. We have a report of
something. And we always are waiting for
hoping for confirmation of more details and just
something important to keep in mind when there are
assertions made in the fog of war, sometimes
the truth ends up being slightly different,
and that is certainly what Russia is hoping for
because of an absolutely disastrous headline.
60 People Killed After Bomb Hits School.
Vladimir Zelensky, the Ukrainian president,
says this is a BBC report. Around 60 people were
killed after a bomb hit a school in east Ukraine,
says President Zelensky. Earlier, the governor
of the Luhansk region, Sergey Heidi, said 90
people had been sheltering in the building and
30 were rescued. Mr. Heidi said a Russian plane
dropped the bomb on Saturday. Russia has not
commented. Luhansk has seen fierce combat as
Russian troops and separatist fighters seek to
surround government forces. Much of the region
has been under the control of Russia backed
separatists for the past eight years. Now
that detail is much of what's being used to say.
Russia would never do this. That's a region there
separatist fighters have been in for so long. But
if we've learned one thing in the last few weeks,
it's even things that lots of people say Russia
would never do. Then Russia does. And though and
so I don't think we can go by that at all. We
also are waiting sort of anxiously to figure out
what is it that might happen on Russia's so-called
victory day today, May 9th. And by the time that
today's episode goes live, you may know more about
this than we know right now. An NBC News article
asks, What does Putin have planned on Russia's
victory day? Experts say that after two months
of sordid, thwarted offensives, Putin is left
with limited options from an all out mobilization
to simply declaring victory in the Eastern
Donbas region. Now, that's an interesting
idea that's being brought up, which is
we don't know Putin's emotional state.
We don't know. Again, increasingly more and more
reports about Putin's ill health. We don't know
whether he is sort of in some kind of unhinged
last attempt at reconstructing the Soviet Union
in some kind of idealized way. We just don't
know what he is capable of and interested in.
But one idea that would be a face saving idea,
absent a victory so far when it comes to Ukraine
at large, would be to say, hey, you know
what? We did it in the sense that we've now
really solidified control of the Eastern
Donbass region. And even though we didn't
take Kiev and some other places further
into Ukraine. Pointing west from Russia,
really this was the goal. And we did it and we
won. We took the Donbas region and of course it
wouldn't be completely true, but it would at least
be more true. Then they took all of Ukraine, which
certainly Russia has not done. So that would be a
kind of face saving way for Putin maybe to start
kind of backing up. But again, we just don't know.
A few other interesting notes from the article,
which says Monday is shaping up to be a pivotal
day for Ukraine. Known as Victory Day in Russia,
May 9th is a national holiday commemorating the
Soviet Union's defeat of Nazi Germany in World War
Two, typically marked by an elaborate
military parade in Moscow's Red Square,
surveyed by senior Kremlin officials. So a little
North Korea like. Yes, for sure. Western officials
have voiced concerns that Putin will use the
occasion to officially declare war on Ukraine,
which Russia invaded in February. Experts say that
after more than two months of thwarted offensives,
Putin is left with limited options. As I said,
an all out mobilization. Or simply declaring
victory in the Eastern Donbas region. Now,
on the declare war thing, we talked a little
bit about declare a war last week during a live
stream. As this article restates, Putin spokesman
Dmitry Peskov denied that a war declaration was
imminent, insisting the invasion remained a,
quote, special military operation. That may be
a nominal difference. As the article points out.
Since Russia has mobilized air, ground and
naval forces across vast areas of Ukraine.
But declaring war would allow Putin to call up
additional army reservists and more people and
could prolong this for a certainly months,
if not years. So at the end of the day,
we don't know what is coming. In the next 24
hours. By the time today's episode is out,
you may know more than I know right now, and we'll
follow up on that tomorrow. But no matter what I
mean, in the best case where Putin says we won in
the sense that we got done, boss, there are going
to be hostilities months or years for sure.
And what this means for the people of Ukraine
can't possibly be particularly good. So we're
going to make an effort this week to make sure
we stay on this story. There have been so many
other things that have happened in the last month.
At the same time as there has been a sort of a
continued steady level of hostilities in Ukraine,
which often when things become normalized, like,
for example, kids dying of hunger every day all
over the world, it becomes less of a corporate
news grab because corporate news stories tend
to have a nice clean beginning, beginning, middle
and end. And if we just remain in the middle for
a long time, sort of like happened with COVID,
as I said, happens with hunger around the world,
it starts to come out of the news and that's
something we're going to try to push back against